Speaker 1: I want to revisit something we talked
about earlier in the week, and we talked about
it with Angelo Carusone for Media Matters, and
we've talked about it in other contexts. Is Fox
News actually turning on Donald Trump? Our best
assessment up until November 7th was. Fox News
isn't really turning on Trump, but they'd rather
someone else be the nominee. They'd rather be done
with Trump. And they are setting up escape hatches
where they can hit the eject button if necessary.
I'm starting to wonder whether Fox News is going
more in the direction of openly turning on Trump.
Now there's a very interesting clip wherein
Stuart Varney interviews Trump's daughter in law,
Lara Trump. Now, this is particularly interesting
because Lara Trump is a Fox News contributor.
So this is not just a guest. This is a
Fox anchor interviewing a Fox employee,
Lara Trump, and he brings to her. VARNEY Does that
announcement on Tuesday night didn't seem very
good. It really didn't seem particularly good.
And it's interesting the way this conversation
goes. Take a look. So I'm sure you're very.
Speaker 3: Supportive of your father in law,
but those of us on the outside looking at
it, it didn't seem as he got the old magic,
you know what I mean?
Speaker 2: Oh, well,
I highly disagree with that. Look for Donald Trump
from the very beginning, from the first day he
came down the escalator in 2015. Right.
Speaker 1: That's the famous speech
where he talked about Mexican rapists.
Speaker 2: In Trump Tower. It's never been
about elected officials, politicians, people,
you know, in the swamp in DC. It's been about
the American people. And if you look around the
room last night, you had people from all different
walks of life. The energy there at Mar a Lago
was absolutely incredible. It really did to me,
feel like the 2015, 2016 campaign all over again.
Speaker 3: Okay.
Speaker 1: So this is Trump's daughter in
law and a Fox News contributor who is paid
for that commentary that you just saw. But
there was no energy in the room. I mean,
we looked at the clips. The energy was so
bad, people were trying to leave and Mar a
Lago staff were keeping them in the room. The
energy was so bad that Jonathan Karl from ABC,
while Trump was speaking, was able to deliver a
live stand up report, not talking particularly
loudly because it was so dead in the room. So
there may be something different going on. I think
it's too early to know. Remember from a couple
of days ago, Maria BARTIROMO, who has been one of
the biggest Trump suck ups for years now. There's
no Trump conspiracy theory. Too crazy for Maria.
She hosted a segment wherein she brought guests on
and even she made comments that are kind of like,
we might be over Trump.
Speaker 2: That's that's the
thing that people keep pushing back on. They don't
want to go into a whole nother storm of hate. And
there is Trump derangement syndrome, right?
Speaker 4: There's definitely tension. And I
think he started even that last night. He started
with the China virus. He started with, you know,
poking names at DeSantis. We've heard that and
people are tired of it. Look, I also think that,
you know, DeSantis and Youngkin, like you said,
are really the future of the party. Right. They're
in a generation that I think needs to come forward
in as much as, you know, his policies were good,
Trump's policies good in the first and the
first term. I don't think the majority of
the country really wants to go back there. I'll
tell you, I live in Florida. Florida's fully
behind DeSantis. No matter what Trump wants
to tell you, they're fully behind the Santos.
Speaker 2: You know, it's interesting.
Ivanka Trump. Ivanka Trump yesterday
said she's bowing out of politics.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Which we covered extensively
already. So, listen, I'll leave the question to
you. Is FOX News proactively bailing on Donald
Trump or are they just leaving themselves an exit?
Let me know in the comments. Make sure that you
were subscribed on YouTube. 3 million of you, 3.2
million of you last month, watched the videos,
didn't subscribe. Let's chip away at that
and get to 2 million subscribers. Make
sure you are subscribed to the YouTube
channel. Quick break. Back after this.
The David Pakman Show is of course an audience
funded program you can sign up at join pacman
dot com the new coupon code please no more Trump
and you type it with no spaces but you have to
think of it in your head as please no more
Trump. It's like a desperation that the guy
not be president again. That code will save you
bigly and you can use it at join pacman dot com.